ha ha
ha
ha ha typische gäste aufgabe im ausland
zum beispiel wäre wie jetzt die
übungsannahme ist das hat sich anna in
area verirrt wo er nicht hingehört und
was es nicht besser und das ist
kampfmittel belastet schrägstrich jetzt
ist es an ihnen dann ist es unser
auftrag und prämisse den man so schnell
als möglich aus dieser situation zu
werden meistens ist es blöd weil werden
wir natürlich schwerst oder schwer
verletzt dies und mehr missen so schnell
als möglich arbeiten und den aus seiner
notlage befreien musik im hintergrund
sieht man genau dass man mails cortina
notfalls bergen und linien in der
notfall sperrung ist es so der haut kz
er muss schnell und präzise arbeiten und
so schnell als möglich zu den
verwundeten kommen
[Musik]
versuche hat schnell und präzise sein
weg zu den schwerstverletzten kunden das
problem ist also dort drückt metall am
körper somit ist sie metallsuchgerät in
dem fall jetzt schon übrig und er muss
den mann und dann um sicher zu sein dass
ich unter ihm kein kampfmittel
schrägstrich mine befindet das dauerte
zurzeit natürlich ist es sehr sehr
schwierig den verletzten im ton zu
halten bei der winterpause aber er
sollte sie dabei war so wenig wie
möglich bewegen da suchen beruhigt ihn
erst darauf speziell geschult damit er
mit dem schwerstverletzten gut umgehen
kann und wer das erledigt hat und den
unter pro rad und sicher sein können
dass ich kein kampf mittelmeer und
befindet werden aus wettbergen durch die
minen pfad
der suche nach kampfmitteln erfolgreich
beendet das schwerstverletzte wird jetzt
aus den kampfmittel belasteten gelände
geborgen dann in eine sichere ärger
gebracht sprich jetzt die straßen und ob
dort beginnt nun die phase 1 der
erweiterte skh das heißt selbst und
kameradenhilfe die zwei kameraden werden
jetzt so gut als möglich
erstversorgen um instabiles zu
stabilisieren und dann
abzutransportieren
[Musik]
durch die gute ausbildung den wir haben
in einer weiter dsk das heißt diese über
110 haben die kameraden jetzt die chance
dass sie ihn stabilisieren dafür ein opa
sport fertigen machen damit wir noch in
einen verbandsplatz sondern einen wagen
halteplatz kommen und dem nur noch einer
qualifizierten versorgung zu führen in
diesem fall ist es nicht möglich dass
das eine kunst oder hubschrauber oder
medien beck wer immer da sind wir befugt
dass wir so weit stabilisieren und ab
kreis partie ein bisschen die erste
möglichkeit
[Musik]